we live in such a sedentary culture
right where we're spending eight ten
sometimes 12 hours a day sitting staring
at our screens so we're living from the
neck up and many of us have lost touch
with the wisdom and the intelligence
that exists in our physical bodies
because simply we're not moving enough
and as someone who has been a Nike
athlete Fitness is a big part of my life
movement is a huge part of my life I see
very clearly when I am moving
consistently I have access it's like a
channel opens up where there is so much
intelligence and so much Insight that
has not to do with my logical reasonable
brain it has to do with another plane
and when I don't I get up here and it
all gets twisted and then I'm unclear so
if you are facing an opportunity a
possibility to say yes to a job a
speaking engagement a date who knows it
could be any realm of life and you're
not sure whether you should move ahead
with it here's what you need to do get
to a place where you're quiet nothing's
around make sure that there's no
technology and I would invite people to
close their eyes while they do this so
ask yourself does the idea of moving
ahead with this of saying yes to this
make me feel expansive or contracted in
the nanosecond after you ask yourself
that question your body will have a
physical response need motivation watch
top 10 with believe Nation hey it's Evan
Carl Michael and I make these videos
because you are probably the most
ambitious person in your circle but you
know you're capable of more and you get
that Push by surrounding yourself with
the best so today let's learn from one
of the best Marie forleo and my take on
her top 10 rules of success enjoy
so let's walk through what expands
everyone who's listening and watching
right now do this yes so expansive and
I'll just give some possibilities but
yours might show up differently so
expansive may actually be as though your
shoulders are relaxing and your chest is
opening up expansive may feel like even
your physical body is moving ahead in
space expansive may feel like a twinge
or a tingle of excitement or Joy or
anticipation even if the notion of this
feels intimidating to you or like
something you've never done before there
is a lightness of moving forward uh ever
so subtle visceral yes whether it shows
up in word form or merely through the
movement of your body that's expansive
now let's look at the flip side if you
ask yourself this question does the idea
of saying yes to this make me feel
expansive or contracted and in the
nanosecond after you ask that question
you find
a pit in your stomach
or a sense of dread or your shoulders
kind of hunching forward or even your
body just shaking back in space or your
head saying no that's your intuition
trying to save your butt until you don't
move ahead with this and here's why this
is so important Jay
because often when we're faced with an
opportunity that our ego thinks we
should move ahead with right either
there's a significant amount of money on
the line or some type of opportunity
that we feel will give us an edge
something beyond the competition or put
us on a level that we're playing in a
field that we're like yeah now we've
really made it
and it looks good on paper but something
inside is like not right that's when we
need to listen to this most and use this
test because I don't know if you've
experienced this when you override those
little feelings of dread even though
everything looks so cool on paper that's
when we get ourselves into trouble and
get off track rule number two get
specific and consistent why do we stop
doing the things that we all know are
good for us especially when we've been
able to make the time before it's a head
scratcher am I right now obviously it
makes no logical sense right but then
again we know that we human beings are
not logical creatures we are emotional
and often irrational when it comes to
our Behavior now the truth is there are
a gajillion different reasons why many
of us stop doing the things that we know
are good for us some people just get
bored right some people rebel against
any kind of structure or authority even
if it's the themselves and some people
get off track like if their schedule
changes or they travel or somebody gets
sick or something like that now as a
coach I'm usually not a big fan of why
questions first because in this format I
can't talk with you I can't get to the
root of your specific situation by
asking you more questions but more
broadly why questions can sometimes
encourage a little bit of Naval gazing
right and they can easily spiral into
beating yourself up thinking that you
suck or that you're just not built to be
consistent and disciplined all of which
is not true so I think a better smarter
and more helpful question is how can I
be more consistent in doing the things
that I know make me feel good or how can
I set myself up to win the vast majority
of time now those questions are
questions that we can tackle plus how
questions really aim your brain towards
the solution right rather than the
problem that's our everything is
figureoutable philosophy in action but
before we we talk about the how I do
want to make something very very clear
April my love you are not bad and you
are not weak for falling off the wagon
of being consistent virtually everybody
I know does stuff like this including me
that's because we are human right we
have this Vision sometimes of these
perfect meditators who meditate twice a
day every day and never ever miss or we
hear about people like Jerry Seinfeld
who write a big X on his calendar every
day he writes a joke and that he never
breaks his streak but guess what even
Jerry Seinfeld doesn't do this Anna
Reddit ask me anything he actually said
this is hilarious to me that somehow I'm
getting credit for making an x on a
calendar with the Seinfeld productivity
program it's the dumbest non-idea that
was not mine but somehow I'm getting the
credit for it Point here is you do not
have to strive to be this perfect person
who does something every single day for
the rest of your life unless that kind
of thing really just floats your boat
now that said there are some systems
that you can easily put in place to make
it easier for yourself to be more
consistent on a consistent basis and
some Behavioral Science that can really
give you an edge step number one is
choose one practice or habit not 17
right so I love that you mentioned all
the kind of things that we like to do in
our morning practices so journaling
exercising all kinds of things like that
and Behavioral Science tells us that if
you want to be successful in terms of
forming a new habit it is best to focus
on one habit not five not ten and
definitely not 27. so I'd encourage you
to ask yourself out of everything that
you could do that feels good which one
habit or one practice is going to give
you the most bang for the buck given
what you want to experience at this
stage and season of your life so is it
riding your bike for those 20 minutes in
the morning or is it something else take
a look inside and then choose one room
number three use your life to the
fullest the average human lifespan is
absurdly insultingly brief assuming you
live to be about 80 you have just over 4
000 weeks
oh I mean did that hit you in the gut
like it hit me
four thousand weeks I don't know about
you but to me that does not seem like a
very long time at all now assuming that
the vast majority of people watching the
show right now are like you meaning you
are not an infant that means you've
already blown through quite a big chunk
of your 4 000 week allotment that is a
sobering wake-up call am I right and you
know I think many of us have been
experiencing what I call the great
reassessment I mean we're still in this
Global pandemic right our entire lives
have been turned upside down and many of
us do not want to go back to the
Breakneck pace of the before times in
fact I think a lot of folks are
reassessing their lives and asking
themselves some very important questions
like how do I want to spend my time
differently moving forward I mean do I
really want to be on my phone for hours
a day looking at social media people try
to convince you how great they are do I
really want to keep working these
punishing 10 to 12 hour days staring at
a computer screen as though I'm going to
get some Grand first prize hustle trophy
at the end or will I ever get to rate
that novel or learn that language or
take more trips or spend more time with
my family while they're actually still
alive I gotta say from my perspective
the great reassessment is actually this
magical window of opportunity to make
some long overdue changes so with that
in mind I'm really curious where are you
in terms of the great reassessment has
this been on your mind lately and in
your heart lately and more specifically
when you think about this notion that on
average in total you get about 4 000
weeks to live and you've likely already
lived a significant portion of that what
specifically do you want to do with the
time you've got left I mean are there
some important dreams and goals that you
really want to prioritize or are there
some unhealthy patterns and habits or
even projects or relationships that no
longer deserve your time or your energy
now I don't want you to just think about
all this right I don't want you to keep
this in your head I want you to actually
write your answers down in the comments
below because writing it down is a part
of what helps you make anything real
because guess what whether You've Got 2
000 or 200 weeks left I'm here to
challenge you to be courageous and
intentional about how you use that
remaining time so here is your
three-part question for this week
question number one what's the one thing
that you're doing right now not because
it's true to your heart but because you
feel it's expected of you I mean maybe
you're doing something out of habit or
obligation but secretly you know that
it's time to move on so that's question
number one
question number two is what's one
courageous change you want to make to be
more true to yourself in terms of how
you spend your time what's one change
that would make you feel great about how
you're using the remaining 2 000 or
however many weeks that you've got left
and then question number three is what's
one action step you can take right now
to start making that change happen so do
you need to make a phone call do you
need to have a conversation is it
something else like signing up for a
class or booking a trip doesn't matter
what it is but I want you to write it
down make it clear specific and
actionable Rule Number Four start before
you're ready when I was first training
in terms of wanting to be a coach and
becoming a coach it was so much in terms
of personal development work and it was
awesome I loved working with clients I
was like 23 24 years old and Not only
was I helping folks try and get results
in their own life I was also doing this
work on myself and one of the things I
realized was that defining myself as a
coach first of all that never really
quite felt right to me it felt very
limiting and narrow and not quite on but
I admitted that I had this dream to
dance now let's set some background no
Dance Training whatsoever never taken a
formal dance class in my life and it was
like I was around 24 25 which sadly in
the professional Dance World it's a
little over the hill to start right
that's a very very late start
and anyway I finally got real at myself
that I wanted to do this and so I
started taking professional dance
classes in New York City and it was
amazing I found myself coming alive and
coming alive and this was great and so I
I um was taking class at Crunch fitness
and my teachers were like you're
actually really good and I remember Jay
I was literally like are you talking
about me I was like wait like I don't
have any technique they're like no no
you should really consider start
teaching and I was like yeah which given
the fact that previous to that I had you
know failed on Wall Street I had failed
in the magazine industry I had all these
failures and I was keeping myself alive
quite frankly because I wasn't earning a
lot of money as a coach by bartending
and waiting table so the fact that
someone thought I was good at something
was that just little grain of like oh
you are kind of good at something it was
great cut to I said all right I'm gonna
try out and become a substitute teacher
at crunch I'm going to teach these
hip-hop classes I had no idea what the
hell I was doing oh you're so cool so I
love that it was just sheer passion
right and I was just doing everything I
could just trying to make it through one
of my first classes ever that I taught
on my own someone came up to me after
class and she said you're really good
and I was like thank you that means the
world to me she's like you know I work
for MTV and we're working on a new show
and we are looking for a choreographer
slash producer you should come in and
Jay it was a moment like this was my
first real class ever again so like
nervous and awkward and unsure of myself
so what came through my head you're not
ready yet that it was like I was even
praying I was like Universe why did this
have to happen I am certainly not ready
I'm not good I don't know what the hell
is going on but this is amazing
opportunity because I grew up on MTV
yeah so I couldn't say no right because
again I could hear my inner clock going
like girl you're not getting any younger
so you might as well say yes so I said
yes to this opportunity and I remember
standing outside of the Viacom building
in New York City the day before I was
like when I was about to go up for this
interview that afternoon and Jay I
wanted to throw up like I was so
nauseous I was so not ready like I was
actually thinking should I throw up in
this like metal trash can or should I
like go inside and go to the bathroom so
that I can clean myself up before I
actually went to the interview
so I went to the building and I stood in
front of the boss's door the the person
who I was going to interview with and I
like shook myself out and I just said
you are not ready but you're gonna start
before you're ready because it's an
incredible opportunity and no matter
what happens you're gonna feel good
about yourself that you just went for it
and I went in for That interview and I
booked the job wow and so it was this
experience of me putting myself into
kind of this whole world that I was in
over my head so let's be clear I was
working with dancers that had decades
more experience than I did they were
talking about dance terms that not only
could I not perform I didn't even know
what the hell they were but I made my
way through by showing up as
professionally as I could by being
honest about my inexperience but also by
bringing my gifts that I did have to the
table and that one opportunity dancing
and choreographing and producing for MTV
that led to Fitness videos that led to
this increase learning curve where I got
to learn basically three to four years
worth of experience in like three months
which eventually led to me
choreographing commercials for Reebok
and then eventually becoming one of the
world's first Nike Elite Dance athletes
all because I was willing to start
before I was ready and every single area
of my life I still do it in business to
this day there's so many things I say
yes to that I'm like somewhere in the
back of my mind like you're not ready
yet and I'm like that means I gotta go
that means I gotta strap myself in and
go like we're doing this I will learn as
I go yeah so this idea of starting
before we're ready it doesn't mean that
we're irresponsible doesn't mean that we
don't do our research and it doesn't
mean that we override our intuition that
if perhaps you know there was years ago
and I'll say this that people approach
me to write a book yes and I
legitimately wasn't ready yet but it was
because my focus was in other areas so I
had other priorities I knew from a
deeper level it wasn't about the fear it
was about trusting my own timing yes but
when you know you want to do something
and you're clear that this is your path
using the Mantra start before you're
ready is an amazing way to beat
procrastination to LeapFrog over your
fear and to get going also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five activate your
imagination there's a prompt in here
that I've used so many times in my life
and so many times in my business that
has trained transformed everything in a
business context it's led to like
multi-million ideas and in a life
context oh my goodness I can't even tell
you how many things it's helped me shift
and it all comes back to tapping into
that wisdom that I already have in my
heart that I wasn't really aware of so
what you're going to need is a journal
or just a notebook or a piece of paper
and I want you to give yourself at least
15 to 20 minutes of uninterrupted time
with no cell phones around no things
bringing or dinging no televisions no
nothing I just need you to put yourself
in a place where it can be kind of quiet
where you're really comfortable maybe
you have a little cup of tea or cup of
coffee or something stronger if that's
what you're into whatever floats your
boat and you're going to use this
sentence stem to start to unearth what
Ellen might really want to focus on in
this next chapter of her life so the
sentence stem goes like this wouldn't it
be cool if dot dot dot so I want you to
write down on a paper wouldn't it be
cool if and then whatever Springs up in
your mind and your heart I just want you
to write it down so wouldn't it be cool
if I lived in Hawaii wouldn't it be cool
if I could solve world hunger wouldn't
it be cool if I had platinum blonde hair
I don't know I'm just making stuff up
off the top of my head but what this
exercise does is it starts activating
your imagination it starts dusting off
that ability you have to dream that I
suspect may have been put on the back
burner for so many years because you've
been focused on so many other people
because you're so responsible and you're
so loving and you're such a good person
but now my friend Ellen now is the time
for you to ReDiscover what's in your
heart and what would really be cool for
you to focus on in this next chapter and
I promise you if you play with this
prompt wouldn't it be cool if and you
let yourself dream without editing
without squashing something down because
you feel like oh that's impossible that
could never happen no we don't do that
in brainstorming we let everything down
on the page I promise you you will start
to unearth something that's going to
make you go
that feels amazing could I really do
that could I really be that could I
really pursue that and you're gonna get
like little tinglies arms will stand
yeah the arm hair will stand up all that
kind of good stuff but it will only
happen if you give yourself this ability
to play with this prompt and do it until
you can't write anymore rule number six
reinvent yourself my question how can I
go about projecting myself as a writer
first and a teacher second what business
steps can I take to make this
transformation thank you for all you do
Christina all right so Christina we got
some good answers for you today there's
actually three very simple very
effective things that you can do right
now to make that transformation and make
it happen fast
the first one is speak it so words have
tremendous power all you got to do next
time you find yourself at a cocktail
party just say you're a writer first so
anytime you introduce yourself talk
about writing talk about your books talk
about everything else before you start
saying you're a teacher and that's going
to make a huge difference so um what we
like to say is just do it
just do it just do it Christina number
two number two you want to write it so
all language that goes out into the
world think about this what is your
email signature say what does your
business card say what about any social
media profiles the very first thing that
you should have is ding ding ding writer
so if you don't have writer as the first
thing listed on all of your written
paraphernalia go and make that change
right now I'll wait foreign do it did
you just do it okay good
um number three and this is the most
important one of all is be it you have
to write as much as you can so if you
don't have a Blog I would highly suggest
you start blogging perhaps journaling
will be more your thing but just really
be the writer that you actually are and
it becomes pretty simple if you're doing
something habitually you're writing
every day you're putting out blog posts
you're publishing more books naturally
it's going to be the first thing that
pops out of your mouse rule number seven
find your inner wisdom many of the times
what stops us all from figuring
something out is we're afraid right
we're afraid maybe we won't be able to
do it or we're just afraid of the area
that we need to walk into in order to
figure it out and then people often have
asked me you know well how do I know the
difference between healthy fear that
would be very good for me to move
through versus my Intuition or a gut
instinct or a hunch going no no no no no
that's out actually gonna be a show
right like that's just gonna be it's
it's something you should not do and
that's a really important question
here's what's awesome you don't need to
go asking other people for the answer
you have all of the wisdom you need
inside of you rule number eight get
clarity once I got back from the
everything is figureoutable tour in the
fall I immediately started cranking on
this idea for a program that would help
people transform their entire
relationship with time I had this Google
doc with like 50 pages of notes and
ideas then of course the pandemic hit in
2020 and everything in my world got put
on ice so cut to the fall and as many of
you guys know I learned I had to have
this urgent hysterectomy and then after
I recovered I was like oh my goodness
now I know I really need to create time
genius like now but then I wondered to
myself is this just me who feels like I
am done with these crazy unrealistic
expectations into terms of all the stuff
that we're supposed to be doing like all
the time am I the only one who feels
like this 24 7 hustle culture is not
only dumb but totally dangerous now as
you probably know I'm very good at
trusting my instincts but before I was
about to invest an enormous amount of my
personal time and my personal energy not
to mention my team's time and energy
creating this whole new comprehensive
experience from scratch I wanted to make
sure that I was creating something that
could genuinely make a difference to our
people which means you I mean were other
people hungry for a new way to work and
live was everybody as disillusioned with
the culture of busyness as I was so we
sent out this survey to find out so I
asked what's your single biggest
struggle when it comes to productivity
and getting things done and then I asked
this if you could ask me any question
about this topic what would you ask now
check this out in the first three days
we had over 7 000 incredible responses I
spent days and days and days reading
through all the answers and honestly
what people shared brought me to tears
it became crystal clear right away that
this wasn't just me right there are
literally thousands of you that are
feeling like all this overwhelm and this
busyness and this pressure is not only
exhausting but it's unsustainable now
once we got that survey back that's when
I knew right that was my 100 this is
what I'm gonna do I am so clear so the
next step was for me to fully commit to
the number one thing that I wanted to
focus on for the rest of the year and as
I teach in time genius Clarity is key to
accomplishing any big dream because it
allows you to blissfully ignore the
endless new opportunities that are going
to keep coming your way rule number nine
be happier I think it's so important and
honestly the place that we've all been
right for the last 18 months and we
don't know how much longer until as a
global Society we can get the pandemic
behind us we don't know where we're at
with that and uh for me having a joyful
life it's like we work so hard everyone
listening right now they work so hard to
take care of their families to take care
of themselves to try and do their best
by their community and all the people
that they have responsibilities towards
and sometimes I've experienced this
where it's like you're exhausted you're
burnt out you just feel like I've got
nothing else to give and I'm like this
is not how we're designed to live
there's like what's the point do you
know what I mean of working so hard even
if you're making great money or you're
making an impact if you're you yourself
aren't happy and joyful if you are not
having a good time along the way it's
all for naught again I get really
obsessed with those end of life studies
and um because people tell us right we
have this incredible data and research
from thousands of souls who have gone
before us who have reached the end of
their life and they have insight and
wisdom to share and almost all of them
said I think it was maybe like the third
or fourth regret this is Bonnie brownie
wears uh the five regrets of the dying
the top five regrets of the dying almost
all of them said I wished I allowed
myself to be happier
I wish I allowed myself to be happier
and when you really stop and think about
that and I'm paraphrasing a little they
might have not gotten the words
perfectly right but that was the essence
of it
I allowed myself to be happier and Evan
I don't know have you experienced this
have you ever gone through periods of
life where you you put your head down
and you worked really hard and maybe you
stressed out and you're like gosh that
was done but it wasn't that enjoyable I
mean I certainly have you know yeah for
sure Orchard myself I just was so tight
and so constricted and I realized I'm
like all of these different little
seasons of my life when you string them
together are my life so if I don't train
myself to bring joy to as many moments
as possible it's not always going to
happen and there's some really crappy
hard things that happen in all of our
lives so this is not about being no
toxic positivity this is not about being
unrealistic but there's many times
throughout my day where i'm like I could
be enjoying myself a lot more right like
if I'm working on something I can bring
that party to whatever I'm doing and
oftentimes especially when there's those
tedious tasks that we all have to do
whether it's emptying your dishwasher or
doing the laundry pipe breaks right you
have to clean something up these are the
things that all of us go through your
car breaks down something unexpected
happens in your life oh my goodness
you can either go handle that from a
place of being just angry and upset and
complaining and beating yourself or the
world up why is it like this or I've
decided I'm like as much as humanly
possible I want to bring the party which
means I'm going to turn on some music
I'm gonna laugh at myself I'm gonna
laugh at life because stuff happens that
you don't expect and it can either be a
show or it can be like you know what
that hi so I might as well have a good
time with it and I think one of the
experiences of being a Time genius is to
also prioritize what brings you Joy so
is it laying in the grass and staring at
the clouds is it allowing yourself some
non-guilty time on the couch to watch
your favorite Netflix show is it being
with your dog or with your kids or
cooking a meal or just reading a great
novel I think that we did research with
our audience Evan and we have responses
from I think at this point it's over 15
000 folks about how they feel about
their time and I was so struck by how
many people feel guilty and feel like
they're not productive enough the moment
they slow down and try and take a rest
that there was no joy that they they
didn't even feel like they deserved to
feel joyful because any time that they
kind of looked away from work they had
this overwhelming thought that they
should be doing something more
productive so the reason for me to
emphasize Joy and time genius is not
because it works but it's also because
it's so necessary I don't want to see
any of us myself you anyone who's
turning tuning in right now and Rule
Number 10 the last one before some very
special bonus Clips is keep going I
think all of us have to you know we need
to give ourselves permission to have
those bad days because we all have them
you know people often ask me they're
like you know you seem so confident all
the time and you seem like you have
everything together and I'm like well
you don't see me when I'm struggling
like you know I'm like on the phone with
a friend going like I don't know if this
is any good or I don't know if X Y and Z
is working or you know kind of those
things that we just do in in private
quite frankly so I think knowing that
all of us have bad days and you'd be
like oh this is the worst But to answer
your question I think it's understanding
that we have the power to assign any
situation either an empowering meaning
or a disempowering meaning so let's take
a really simple example right so we're
not gonna get too heavy we're gonna do
it just right on the surface because
sometimes it's easier to see like the G
juice example totally so
let's say I am a first-time writer and
I've sent out my manuscript and I got
rejected again
I can take that very neutral fact and
assign a meaning or a story to it that
says well
I'm a failure no one likes my and I
should just give up and I should stop
being a writer clearly because here's
another rejection letter so that is what
I would categorize as a disempowering
meaning you're not going to feel good
you're probably not going to take a
productive effective action from that
state of mind and you may not ever reach
your ultimate dream of being perhaps a
published writer
you could choose to assign that same
neutral fact an empowering meaning which
could be and we can come up with tons of
them maybe it's like you know what
every rejection means I'm One Step
Closer To Success because I'm actually
getting my work out there and if I'm
getting my work out there that means
that I could possibly be published you
could assign an empowering meaning like
this that particular article or story
wasn't right for that publisher they're
not rejecting me they're rejecting the
work let me go find another publisher
that might be aligned with this
particular story you could also make it
mean something like this you could say
you know what I remember that JK Rowling
got rejected 12 times and I think
Stephen King's Carrie got rejected like
30 times I just need to keep going and
build up even more rejection and this
isn't about being Pollyanna it's
understanding the power that we have of
perception and our ability to assign a
meaning to any fact that presents itself
to us and I think there's something
interesting there's this great quote
life is 10 what happens to me and ninety
percent how I react to it Chuck's
Swindle right Pastor I love that because
there are going to be hard truths in all
of our lives and I feel like the only
thing that we can control is how we
contextualize what happens and therefore
how we respond to what happens does that
answer that question definitely answers
that question I love the multiple ways
in which you gave of rewiring that same
thought with different meaning and
stories well I think that's it forces us
to be creative right so it's like we
have to challenge ourselves to see the
same exact thing from multiple points of
view one of the things we'll talk about
this a little later but I also love
showing people
um optical illusions where you can see
multiple things in the same exact lines
or drawings because it proves that we
can all look at the same facts and have
a completely different interpretation
which therefore proves that the
situation is not what is bad or good but
the labels and the context and the
stories that we lay on top of it totally
I was bartending at night waiting tables
doing assistant work like I was
basically working 24 7 you know in the
evenings and weekends it was all how can
I just make money to pay my rent and put
food on the table and in the days I was
really working my buns off trying to
create content create a newsletter get
coaching clients actually start working
with people and
um when I got engaged really young I was
about 23 years old and the guy was a
sweetheart but I realized pretty quickly
I didn't want to marry him this was not
the person I was meant to spend the rest
of my life with but we lived in this
tiny one-room studio in the West Village
and our money was already co-mingled and
so I was terrified because I felt like I
made this huge mistake here I am trying
to become a life coach and clearly I
have a lot to figure out about life I
knew I needed to get out of this
relationship but I didn't I didn't know
how to untangle what I had created this
big mess and so um I knew once I broke
off and engagement I needed to actually
physically leave that environment that
was the only way I was going to get to
move on and so I called my parents New
Jersey and I said I hate to say this but
I have to move home I was so upset I
just felt like a total failure I felt
like a horrible person for breaking this
guy's heart and it was just it was a
mess like I just felt like such a
failure on every single level the fact
that I couldn't support myself yet the
fact that I had to go back to Jersey the
fact that I felt like I you know did a
number on this guy's life and um and was
really humbling but you know at the end
of that it made me realize I'm more
committed than ever to figure out what
it takes to make my life work and then
also to be able to share those lessons
with other people so hopefully they
didn't have to go through the mess that
I created if I could save people a
learning curve that was going to be
awesome and I think I was home maybe
like two or three months something like
that emotionally I had to heal and just
kind of get myself re-situated and you
know find a new living a place to live
in the city and get back on my feet but
it was probably one of the best things
that ever happened to me because it got
me regrounded in my own power and made
me realize that if everything falls
apart which it sometimes does there's
always a way to get back on your feet as
I approached the gate I knew I needed to
get some work done before hopping on
that flight and I was bracing to try and
find one of those like long vertical
Outlet hubs where there's 30 people
clustered around trying to plug their
stuff in so to my very pleasant surprise
I found Rose and Rose and rows of these
comfortable cute little workstations all
with their own outlets and a huge sign
above it that said the juice bar I mean
seriously how many times have you said
to yourself oh crap I've ran out of
juice on my phone or my computer has
zero juice I need to go find a plug so
when JetBlue says juice bar they are
speaking my language and it's a very
smart plan words that lets me know hey
they get me and I gotta tell you this
every single customer wants to feel like
you as a business owner just get them
now another quick example uh when I saw
the help desk right instead of saying
something formal like information desk
the sign said just ask so not only is
the latter more friendly and inviting
but it implies that my question is
welcome and not stupid so the bottom
line is this using your customers
language is key if you want to create
more sales and raving fans and in the
words of this tweetable your customers
language is the jet fuel to make your
business take off everyone asks us from
the time that we're like in our kind of
mid-teens and when you start thinking
about you know what you're going to
major in and where you're going to go to
college and what you're going to do it's
like what do you want to do when you
grow up and it's this question that I
think is really intimidating first of
all because when we're young we might
not have that answer yet and in my case
there were a lot of things that I wanted
to do I remember having such a passion
for dance although I never took any
formal dance training until I was like
in my mid-20s I love to dance I was
passionate about fitness and health I
loved spirituality I loved reading I
loved business I actually thought at one
point I was going to be an animator for
Disney so I think that part of my own
Challenge and my struggle was that most
of the world was telling me that I had
to pick one thing and all this
conventional wisdom was like if you're
going to be a success you have to narrow
down pick one thing specialize in it and
be the best at that thing and maybe in
like 10 or 20 years you're going to be
awesome and every time I tried to follow
that conventional wisdom that told me to
pick one thing I felt like I was cutting
off a limb even when I you know tried to
just pick life coaching and I was like
I'm just gonna be a life coach I felt
horrible I felt terrible when I decided
that I was actually going to give dance
which was hip hop dance and and fitness
a go thinking like okay I'm just
supposed to do this just doing that I
felt terrible thinking I was putting
life coaching on the back burner and it
wasn't until I realized that I am a
multi-passionate person I am
multifaceted there are a lot of things
that I'm not only interested in but I'm
actually good at and I need to give
myself permission to do everything and
just run away from the conventional
wisdom that's actually when I started
feeling good about myself and that's
when I actually started getting Traction
in the world and when I say traction I
mean started getting better projects
started getting paid more started
actually building skills that now are
crucial for my business the most
accomplished and respected people in the
world stay humble they're curious
they're open-hearted they're lifelong
Learners don't ever feel like you have
to overcompensate for imposter syndrome
by becoming an arrogant asshat know it
all not only do you not have to know it
all but you become extra trustworthy
when you say these three magic words I
don't know
you know I consider myself a forever
student and I happily admit when I have
no idea what something is or how to do
something but you know what everything
is figure outable so not knowing doesn't
make me a fraud and it doesn't have to
make you one either and vision is great
some people have amazing huge big Grand
visions and they love it and they step
into it and they rise up to that
occasion and that's awesome like if
that's you and that's how you're built
and that's what works for you rock on
for many people when they have an
enormous Vision it paralyzes them they
have no idea how to accomplish it I see
people crying workshops all the time
it's so big I don't know how to do it I
want to change the world I'm like don't
worry about changing the world change
one person's life if we can focus there
stay there for a little bit we're gonna
get to that thing maybe otherwise it's
all good because you're still doing the
work that you were born to do I always
had a dream to have an amazing company
that didn't necessarily have one home
base I'm fascinated by technology and
for me it's about finding the right
people who also believe in that same
idea that you can do great work that you
don't necessarily have to share the same
physical space all the time but that if
you're United behind a vision and behind
values and behind wanting to do
incredible work in this world that you
can create amazing results and only see
each other a couple times a year so for
us it's really about making sure that
whoever comes onto the team shares the
same beliefs that we do shares the same
vision cares about making a difference
and also is really self-motivated you
know just because I'm the CEO of my
company everyone else in the company is
very entrepreneurial they might not want
to run a company themselves but they're
self-starters they're completely
motivated they're always looking for
ways to solve problems they have an
attention on the bottom line and they
want to create huge change in this world
we honestly don't think about our own
mortality enough I think death is one of
those taboo kind of Topics in our
culture and we don't really face it that
we don't think about it we don't talk
about it enough we don't imagine
ourselves dying enough we don't really
just dive in and one of the weird little
tricks that I use on myself especially
when I'm just being horrible in my own
relationship or I'm being not the person
I know I'm capable of being I'm having a
temper tantrum I'm stressed I'm just
being an ass whatever it is I've used
this in my relationship with Josh where
I will literally fast forward to the
point where like I imagine him
laying in a coffin and me going why were
you such an [ __ ] why didn't you take
that time why did you let that fight go
on for four hours or a day or whatever
it is or in those moments where I feel
myself tightening up or shutting down or
withholding love I try and check myself
before I wreck myself I go there's going
to come a day where you're going to
flash back on this moment and wished
that you just gave him a hug
or wish that you went in and said I love
you
it's coming
for all of us
so if you can remember that
now
you change everything when I was first
starting b-school I was really excited
about getting it out into the world and
I went to a marketing conference to
network and to meet people and Define
promotional partners and so I was really
excited to tell people about the program
and I was on this escalator heading up
to like the first session of the day I
was really excited and there's this guy
in front of me and you know at
conferences everybody likes to introduce
ourselves and learn about what you do
and so this guy looks at me and he
looked at my name tag and goes oh you
know what do you do what are you doing
here sorry I started telling him about
b-school this online business school for
women entrepreneurs and his face kind of
went blank and he looked at me and he's
like oh that's cute do you expect to
make money with that do you have a rich
husband who's bankrolling you
and I was so stunned that this guy said
this right to my face meanwhile the
truth was that I was supporting myself
in my own business for almost a decade
at that point I had already been making
quite good money and no I did not have a
rich husband
um it took everything in me not to want
to really deck this guy and throw him
off the escalator but it was probably
one of the moments that fired me up so
much because this guy saying something
so rude and so chauvinistic to me all it
did was get me more fired up to prove
him and anyone out there who underested
me underestimated me completely wrong I
was believing that if I didn't work
constantly that I wasn't a worthy person
that I wasn't doing enough to make my
business successful that I was perhaps
letting people down and so I had to
really shift that and understand that
you know I come from a background I
don't come from a wealthy background so
the work ethic in my nuclear family is
very strong like my my dad owned a small
business my mom although she stayed home
with us she was constantly doing stuff
constantly working constantly fixing
things constantly doing things that took
care of the family so that's the kind of
DNA I grew up with was like no if
something needs to get done you get it
done it's not like you sit around all
day and eating bonbons and watching TV
so
um yeah so so that's kind of how I got
there but then I really I had to
readjust if I actually wanted to not
only have a successful business but have
a successful life
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to see the last one-on-one I did
with the amazing Marie forleo check it
out right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there most of us exist in
this space of endless comparison the
compare and despair right so we have
either these idealized versions of
ourselves